you can easily judge the character of a man by
how he treats those who can do nothing for him
many people take no care of their money
till they come nearly to the end of it
and others do just the same with their time
nothing is worth more than this day
of all the thieves idiots are the most
harmful they steal from us our time and mood
if you treat an individual as he is he will remain
how he is but if you treat him as if he were
what he ought to be and could be he will
become what he ought to be and could be
what you get by achieving
your goals is not as important
as what you become by achieving your goals
remember to live
life is too short to drink bad wine
what is not started today
is never finished tomorrow
doubt can only be removed by action
those who stopped loving and making
mistakes have buried themselves alive
no one would talk much in society if they
knew how often they misunderstood others
the most ridiculous desire is
the desire to please everybody
too many parents make life hard for their children
by trying too zealously to make it easy for them
what is uttered from the heart alone
will win the heart of others to your own
whoever wishes to keep a secret must
hide in the fact that he possesses one
everybody wants to be somebody
but nobody wants to grow
who is the happiest of men
he who values the merits of others and in their
pleasure takes joy even as though twere his own
oblivion is full of people who allow the opinions
of others to overrule their belief in themselves
inspiration is not a herring which
can be pickled for many years
we all of us live upon the past and
through the past we are destroyed
he is happiest be he king or
peasant who finds peace in his home
there is no past we can
bring back by longing for it
there is only an eternal now that builds and
creates out of the past something new and better
for a man to achieve all that is demanded of
him he must regard himself as greater than he is
he who moves not forward goes backwards
to be pleased with one's
limits is a wretched state
love is an ideal thing marriage is a real thing
one always has time enough
if one will apply it well
the best government is that which
teaches us to govern ourselves
we know accurately only when we know
little with knowledge doubt increases
our friends show us what we can do
our enemies teach us what we must do
destiny grants us our wishes but in its own way
in order to give us something beyond our wishes
the intelligent man finds almost everything
ridiculous the sensible man hardly anything
do not give in too much to feelings
a overly sensitive heart is an
unhappy possession on this shaky earth
go to foreign countries and you will get to
know the good things one possesses at home
character is formed in the
stormy billows of the world
knowing is not enough we must apply
willing is not enough we must do
the way you see people is the way you treat them
and the way you treat them is what they become
as soon as you trust yourself
you will know how to live
the greatest thing in this world is not so much
where we stand as in what direction we are moving
kindness is the golden chain by
which society is bound together
everything is hard before it is easy
there is nothing in the world more shameful
than establishing oneself on lies and fables
nothing shows a man's character
more than what he laughs at
the greatest evil that can befall man is
that he should come to think ill of himself
i can tell you honest friend what to believe
believe life it teaches better that book or orator
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to
see the next video subscribe
you